mais oui
pour une humanité en eaux troubles
l'eau est en danger nous drainant le
sang de l'humanité par une
surconsommation vampirique et nous ont
causons l'évaporation par le
réchauffement climatique lance le
secrétaire général
une personne sur quatre dans le monde
est privé d'eau potable un chiffre qui
pourrait doubler en moins de 10 ans et
3,6 milliards de personnes n'ont pas
accès à des latrines toilettes ou
système d'assainissement des eaux usées
les pressions sont multiples croissance
démographique consommation et
changements climatiques la consommation
mondiale d'eau augmente 2% par année
depuis 40 ans et la demande des villes
elle augmentera de 80% d'ici 2050
menaçant la production alimentaire
partout dans le monde maintenant les
municipalités les villes vont chercher
dans le milieu agricole l'eau qu'elles
ont besoin pour alimenter leur
population donc il y aura de plus en
plus de conflits d'utilisation sur le
territoire le Canada détenteur de 20% de
l'eau douce la planète menace ses cours
d'eau des pesticides et des herbicides
et des fertilisants agricoles une
trentaine de communautés autochtones
n'ont même pas accès à de l'eau potable
et le manque de données sur les
quantités d'eau prélevés au pays empêche
le gouvernement de faire une bonne
gestion de la ressource
d'ailleurs on ne peut pas gérer ce qu'on
ne connaît pas et puis non seulement
qu'on devrait avoir les données mais ces
données de prêtres devrait être
publiques absolument à Ottawa ou
reconnaît les défis et on mise entre
autres sur la modernisation de la loi
sur l'eau et la création de nouvelles
agences que nous voulons faire avec
cette agence là ce n'est pas de
dupliquer ce qui existe déjà mais c'est
de lui donner ce rôle de coordination à
l'échelle fédérale mais aussi de
travailler avec les provinces les défis
sont nombreux préviennent l'ONU et
admisent sur l'aide internationale et la
coopération pour calmer la crise
humanitaire qui se tram à l'horizon ici
Elisa serrer Radio-Canada Montréal